I was six my babysitter was murdered and  they never caught him justice was done  wanna play  [Music]  okay the murders were real  Sookie livery was that's right he was a  fantasy a delusion are you feeling  better now I don't blame you for being  afraid I was very ill Chucky told me  he's coming for you it's important that  we all explore it together as a group I  think I have something that will help  whoa all right I'm Chucky wanna play  [Music]  first I'll kill each and every one of  you the most horrible ways you can  imagine and then he'll kill me too  [Music]  are you afraid of the truth terrified  you should be too  night night and they call me sick  waiters told them  a 2000 ever goes out of style  [Music]